we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and this
caller contacted me about bernie sanders
lack of jewish support despite being a
Jewish candidate take a listen
hi David I was quietly you know that
have recently been seeing polls that
among Jewish voters Bernie Sanders is
struggling he's only at like eleven
percent at some polls I've seen him at
eight percent yeah that was pretty any
red flags why do you think that is yeah
I'd love to hear yeah so listen a couple
of things going on number one Bernie's
eleven percent support from Jewish
voters was before Super Tuesday and with
a bunch of candidates bailing my guess
is that Jewish support for Bernie would
be a little bit higher right now the
truth is a couple different things
number one I don't actually believe that
despite being a Jewish candidate I don't
think Bernie's winning or losing depends
on Jewish support one-and-a-half to two
and a half percent of the US population
is Jewish maybe three percent by the
highest estimates so mathematically this
is not a big deal it is interesting
however when it comes to an identity
sort of question I think that the answer
is relatively clear which is that Jewish
voters overwhelmingly vote Democratic
but many Jewish voters aren't thrilled
with some of the people that Bernie
Sanders has around him because of their
backgrounds and relationships to the
Jewish community Linda Sarsour comes to
mind the recent endorsement from Jesse
Jackson who although he's since
apologized was involved in at least a
couple of anti-semitic incidents in the
80s which is a very long time ago
admittedly but that image probably has
not been been sort of fixed so to speak
in the end I believe Jewish voters will
still overwhelmingly vote for the
Democratic candidate no matter who it is
if it's Bernie almost all Jewish voters
will vote for Bernie over Trump if it's
Biden they'll vote for Biden Jewish
voters are one of the most reliable
left-leaning voting groups in the United
States but I think that the reason
you're seeing what you're seeing in
terms of lack of Jewish support for
Bernie has very little to do with
Bernie's position on
israeli-palestinian conflict which to me
is a pretty reasonable position it's
Israel has a right to both exist and
defend itself and we need to treat the
Palestinians with dignity and the
current Israeli administration of
Benjamin Netanyahu is not going to be a
likely arbiter for peace I tend to agree
with his position I also don't like a
lot of the people Bernie has around him
although it wouldn't keep me from voting
for him I just don't like it and I think
it's mistaken that perspective could be
different among other Jewish voters let
me know what you think and join us on
the bonus show we will talk today more
on the bonus show about the Jesse
Jackson endorsement of Bernie Sanders we
will talk about Kamala Harris endorsing
Joe Biden will talk about yes daylight
saving time once again the conversation
is happening and we will talk about
Trump firing his chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney it was just a matter of time
join us on the bonus show either by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show